QUORUM YET BUT WE CAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO THE MARCH TWELFTH
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES.
COMMITTEE WE HAVE FIVE BILLS ONE
RESOLUTION ON THE AGENDA WITH
ONE BILL ON CONSENT.
AS A REMINDER WE LIMIT TESTIMONY
DUE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH
WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
MAY ADD ON BY STATING THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
AS A COURTESY I WILL BE ALLOWING
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN TO PRESENT
FIRST TODAY.
ARE YOU WILL BE PRESENTING OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AS
BILL ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AS WELL AS HIS OWN.
WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM --
WE WILL TAKE ROLE AT THAT TIME.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- AND
THANK YOU FOR THE COURTESY AS
WELL WHAT IS OUR GIVE A
PREFERENCE WHICH BILL I PRESENT
FIRST.
OKAY SO I'LL START WITH --
A. B. THREE THIRTY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA -- AS
A STATE WE PASS LAWS TO ENSURE
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE EDUCATION
RIGHTS IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
EDUCATIONAL STABILITY AND
IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REMAIN AT THE SAME SCHOOL EVEN
AFTER THEY ARE MOVED TO A NEW
FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT. TO HELP
FACILITATE THIS PROCESS CARE
GIVERS ARE ENTITLED TO
REIMBURSEMENT FOR PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION TO A CHILD'S
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN.
HOWEVER TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
DOES NOT BEGIN UNTIL THE CARE
GIVER IS APPROVED THROUGH THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS.
WITHOUT IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION REIMBURSEMENT.
A FOSTER USE LIFE CAN BE FURTHER
DISRUPTED THIS IS WHY AB THREE
THIRTY SEVEN IS NEEDED WITH ME
TODAY IS KRISTIN POWER WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
AND JORDAN SO SO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON KRISTIN POWER
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS WERE PRACTICAL SPONSOR
THIS.
MEASURE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION AB THREE THREE
SEVEN ONE HANDS EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES ARE PROMOTE SCHOOL AND
PLACE INSTABILITY BY ENSURING
THAT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE TO
QUALIFY. FOR EDUCATION
TRANSPORTATION REIMBURSEMENT
RECEIVE.
AND DURING THIS TIME OF THE
RESOURCE FAMILIES COMPLETING
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL I WILL
PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH THE NOTICE
OF THEIR RIGHT TO RECEIVE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE COSTS
TRANSPORTING A YOUTH TO THEIR
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN.
WE BELIEVE CARE GIVERS SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL CHILD SCHOOL WHARTON TIME
MAY TAKE PLACE MEANT. TO PROMOTE
SCHOOL PLACEMENT STABILITY FOR
THE CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE. TO
ILLUSTRATE THE ISSUE. TO PREVENT
TO YOUNG PEOPLE FROM HAVING TO
CHANGE SCHOOLS ALLIANCE CLIENTS
JAKE ANNALISE'S AUNT WHO CARED
FOR THEM WHEN THEY WERE REMOVED
FROM THEIR PARENTS TO TWO
ALLEGED ABUSE.
DRIVE THEM FROM CANYON COUNTRY
IN NORTH LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
LA YOU UST ABOUT FIFTY MILES ONE
WAY.
EACH DAY FOR SCHOOL FOR TWO
YEARS.
AFTER TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF AB
ALLIANCE ADVOCACY JAKE AND
MELISSA'S AUNT WAS REIMBURSED
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION SHE HAD
PROVIDED TO ALLOW J. CAMILLUS TO
STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION.
AB THREE THREE SEVEN WILL ALLOW
THAT FUNDING TO BEGIN FROM THE
TIME JAY CAMILLUS THAT WERE
PLACED IN WOULD HAVE PROVIDED
NOTICE EITHER IN THE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
REIMBURSEMENT.
FEDERAL EA TANNA FUNDS COVER THE
MAJORITY OF COSTS FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND SO IT MAKES SENSE TO
AFFORD OUR FOSTER CARE GIVERS
AND THE CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE
ALL AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
WHEN EDUCATION STABILITY
DECISIONS ARE MADE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TORN
SO SO THE STATE WHY POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH CALIFORNIA
YOU'VE CONNECTION HAVE THE HONOR
TO DEFER MY TIME TO NAOMI WATTS
AND HI I'M THE ONLY WATSON AND
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTIONS.
MY CHAPTER SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
WHY EDUCATION STABILITY IS
IMPORTANT FOR ME.
AS A FORMER PASTILLAS --
AS ALWAYS I WAS HOMELESS I WAS
GONNA TRUMP TO JUMP TO PLACE AND
I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT LIKE
WHAT TO DO WHILE STILL TRYING TO
GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE WHEN I USED
TO CALL.
SCHOOL WAS AGO HI THAT WAS MY
HOME BECAUSE THE HOME I WAS.
TECHNICALLY THE HOUSE SO THAT
WASN'T YOU KNOW WASN'T CONNECTED
ME WHEN IT.
ENDS.
WHEN I MOVED INTO FOSTER CARE I
WENT TO A SCHOOL FOR A LITTLE
BIT BUT THEN?
I WANT TO SEE OUR H. SO IT WAS
OF REALLY FAR COMMUTE AND THEY
REALLY WANT TO DO IT ANYMORE AND
SO I WENT.
TO THIS OTHER SCHOOL CAN YOU
REMEMBER AND THEN I MOVED AGAIN
TO THE SCHOOL AND AT ITS CHOICES.
AND MAN.
I GRADUATED BILL LIKE.
IT ALL THESE MOVING IF ONLY I
STILL LIKE MY ONE SCHOOL BECAUSE
NOW AND HOW THAT SAME
CONNECTIONS I HAVE WITH MY YOU
KNOW MY CLASSMATES AND THE
PEOPLE I USED TO CALL LIKE THAT
UP SCHOOLS WHERE I CALLED HOME.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOME WAY YOU
FEEL SAFE IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMEONE THAT YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
CONNECTS TO AND SOMEONE THAT
[inaudible]
IS.
IT'S A POINT OF STABILITY.
YOU KNOW HOW.
IN SOME THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
THAT AND THE FOSTER STABILITY
THAT CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION IS
DOING.
AND EDUCATION IS [inaudible]%
EIGHT I'M SORRY --
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE AND I INCLUDES YOU COMMUNITY
COMMUTE COMMITTEE TO VOTE A FOUR
AND A. B..
THREE THREE FOUR SEVEN THREE
THREE SEVEN SIDE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
YEAH THAT'S LIKE THEY'RE ON
ANOTHER ISSUE BUT I HAPPEN TO BE
IT PASSED PRESIDENT OF FOSTER
CARE LEMME OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER.
AND THE IMMEDIATE PAST CO CHAIR
FOR NATIONAL POLICY OUR
COMMITTEE FOR SCA NATIONAL --
AS A SECOND GENERATION FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND FOR EVERY EDUCATIONAL
MOBILITY OR EDUCATIONAL
PLACEMENT A STUDENT LOSES ABOUT
SIX MONTHS.
OF EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN THE
CLASSROOM SO THIS ISN'T JUST AN
ISSUE OF HAVING CONNECTION
SOCIAL CONNECTION LESSONS BUT
ALSO HAS AN IMPACT ON STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
SO -- BRING
A POND AT CA MEDIA PASSED
PRESIDENT AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I DO WANT TO
REMIND YOU ALL I LIKE TO HAVE
JUST THE NAME AND AFFILIATION.
AND THE JUROR IN FAVOR DANIEL A
CALIFORNIA LINE TO CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SUNDERLAND COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SORRY TO
BUG YOUR RULE BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED WE'RE JUST
WORKING ON A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
RELATED TO THE TIMING OF THE
NOTIFICATION IN THE BILL.
BUT ARE CONFIDENT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO COME ON IN STRONG SUPPORT
ONCE WE DO WORK THAT OUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GENEREX READ WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CNN EPHEMERA CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DANA FRYER CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CARE GIVERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SAYING NONE.
THE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE.
THANK YOU SAYS WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE WILL MOVE THIS FORWARD I
NAOMI THANK YOU I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME.
TO COME HERE TO TESTIFY
OFTENTIMES WHEN WE'RE VOTING ON
BILL SUCH AS THIS WHEN WE HEAR
FROM THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST AFFECTED.
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND MADAM CHAIR --
ON AB.
FOR TWENTY SIX I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED A REQUIREMENT THAT I HSS
APPLICANTS MUST SUBMIT A
STATEMENT A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
THAT THEY NEED IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
THIS FORM IS REQUIRED TO BE
CONSIDERED AS ONE INDICATOR THE
INDIVIDUALS NEED AND NOT THE
SOLE DETERMINING FACTOR
UNFORTUNATELY THIS REQUIREMENT
HAS ACTED AS A BARRIER TO
APPLICANTS.
DOCTORS CHARGE UP TO A HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE FORM AS
IT IS NOT A MEDICAL SERVICE AND
IS NOT COVERED BY MEDICARE.
AB FOR TWENTY SIX WOULD REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT APPLICANTS
SUBMIT THE FORM INDICATING THEIR
NEED FOR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND CLARIFY THAT A
REDUCTION IN AYE HSS HOURS CAN
ONLY OCCUR.
WHEN A VERIFICATION OF CHANGES
JUSTIFIED PHILLIPS KEVIN AS
LONNIE AND WITH THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS?
GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE KEVIN AS
THE NEW COLORS A CALIFORNIA FOR
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THIS BILL WITH WITH THE
STUNT BECAUSE I'VE WE HAVE
COMPLAINTS OF PEOPLE.
WERE BEING CHARGED FOR UP TO A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FILL OUT THE
FORM.
AND THEN WE TALK TO COUNTY
PEOPLE WITH THIS --
AND THE STATE.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR THEM IN THE
BILL CAME FOR THE PREVIOUS
CENTURY --
WILL BE BEFORE KIM CAME FROM THE
SCHWARZENEGGER ADMINISTRATION
WHEN THEY'RE WITH DEEP RECESSION.
AND A THE BILL IS THE LONGER
NECESSARILY AGREE DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING. TO IMPROVE DIE TO JUST
DELIVERY SYSTEM HOWEVER TH WE
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY IS --
TO TO SEE IF THIS IS SOME TO
SOME EXCEPTIONS THAT THEY WANT
ONE AS WE GO ALONG WITH WITH
DEAL WITH THAT --
WE HAVE THREE OF A VOTE THANK
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AFTER NAY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BEVERLY YOU ON BEHALF OF U. D.
W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY WOULD LIKE TO LINE OR
COMMENTS WITH THE SPONSOR AND
AUTHORS OFFICE AND OR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA VERY STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHRISTIE'S BUT THE BRIDGE IT ON
HAVE EDUCATE ADVOCATE EMPOWER
FAMILY CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
DO NOT HAVE A POSITION AT THIS
TIME -- FROM
THE COUNTY PERSPECTIVE THERE IS
VALUE IN THE MEDICAL
CERTIFICATION FORM FOR BOTH
SOCIAL WORKERS AND THE
RECIPIENTS.
I'M AS THE SPONSOR MENTION WE'VE
ENGAGE THE AUTHOR ON THE SPONSOR
ON PERHAPS ALTERNATE WAYS TO
ADDRESS THAT THERE IS A THEY'VE
IDENTIFIED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSION.
THANKS.
KATHY CENTERING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
I'LL JUST ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
MR GARRETT'S COMMENTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING THROUGH
IT THANKS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
NOT SAYING NONE QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS.
THAT'S YOUR CHOICE.
I WONDER IS A ASSEMBLYMAN
MAIENSCHEIN WHAT THE MOTIVATED --
YOU OF BEER HERE DID YOU RECEIVE
ANY US SUGGESTIONS OF FROM THE
COUNTIES A FOR THIS WAS THE
BURDEN TO THE COUNTY SO WHY
DIDN'T THEY SO YES INITIATE THE
BILL SO WE HAD WORKED --
WITH KEVIN AND HIS ORGANIZATION
IT THERE HAD BEEN --
REPORTS THAT THAT BECAUSE OF THE
REQUIREMENT OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS
THAT WAS OUTSIDE OF THE MEDIC
COW THAT IT RESULTED IN --
INABILITY OR AT LEAST A
DISRUPTION FOR PEOPLE TO GET THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEEDED AND
WAS IT CERTAINLY UNCLEAR AT
LEAST FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OUR RESEARCH OF THIS BILL.
THAT THIS WAS PROVIDING SOME
SORT.
OF BENEFIT.
SO YOU'LL FEEL ORDER RELIEVE --
ANY BURDEN FOR THE OF CURRENT.
RECIPIENTS SO FAR I IT'S IT'S
IT'S SERVICES THAT'S THE IDEA
BEHIND THE BILL MISTER.
THANK [inaudible]
THE OTHER.
NOBODY ELSE TO ASK QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURTESY AS WELL IN RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
MR TRUE ITEM ONE A LITTLE
EARLIER.
RIGHT.
CHECK YOUR ROOM IS A MODERN
CHAIRS ARE MEMBERS TIME.
AMONG HERE 2%.
EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY THREE AB TWO
EIGHTY THREE WERE REMOVING TO
DUPLICATE.
REQUIREMENT [inaudible]
AN AGORA. TO A DUPLICATE OF
REQUIREMENTS PLACE ON THE CALL
WORK FAMILY STAY OUR OF FIRST
EMAIL IDEATION REQUIREMENTS AND
THE OTHER ONE WAS THAT JUNE WITH
REGRESSIVE --
FINANCIAL PENALTIES --
DROUGHT WAS TO NOT WORK AS
INTENDED SO OF FOR EXAMPLE A
FAMILY OF TWO IN SAN JOSE WILL
BE PENALIZED.
FOR TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO PER
MONTH FOR KNOWN COMPLIANCE
THAT'S ABOUT 30%.
OFF THEIR BENEFIT CHAT DAY OF
DEALS RATHER HE WILL REALLY TAKE
AWAY THE FOOD ON THE TABLE AND
KEEP.
GUESTS ALL OF THE TANK.
SO DO A BILL WILL BRING A
WELFARE AND INSTITUTE
INSTITUTIONAL CLOTHING INTO A
LION.
WITH THE OTHER PORTION OF
CALIFORNIA LAW RELEVANT TO
TRUANCY AND HUMAN LIFE IN MY
LIFE DACIAN.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK REPORT IS --
JESSE BOTTLE OF TO YOU WESTERN
CENTER OF LONG M. PROPERTY.
AND JENNER'S CONALL OWN OFFERED
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND.
HI MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE JESSICA BARTLETT WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY --
AS YOU HEARD THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAY -- THESE --
CURRENT PENALTIES AND THE LAWS
ARE DEEP AREAS WHERE FAMILIES
ARE IN ENCOURAGED AND IN FACT
REQUIRED T. TO IMMUNIZE THEIR
CHILDREN OR REQUIRE THAT THEIR
CHILDREN ATTEND SCHOOL.
IT IS SCIENCE SHOWS THAT
IMMUNIZATIONS ARE GOOD FOR KIDS
AND THEY'RE NOT ONLY GOOD FOR
KIDS THEY'RE GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT --
CLINICALLY DISEASES A STATE TO A
MINIMAL AND THAT PEOPLE'S HEALTH
AND WELL BEING --
IS PROTECTED.
WE SWEATERS AND ALONG POVERTY
SUPPORTS IMMUNIZATION UP BUT IF
YOU BELIEVE IN SCIENCE THEN YOU
ALSO BELIEVE --
THE REPORT AND THE NUMEROUS
RESEARCH RESEARCH HAS BEEN DONE
THAT PROVE THAT MAKING A FAMILY
POOR --
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HELP THEM TO
BECOME VACCINATED.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN SCIENCE YOU
KNOW THE REPORTS SAY THAT IF YOU
ATTEND COLLEGE HIGH SCHOOL AND
YOU --
FINISH SCHOOL YOU'RE MORE LIKELY
TO EXIT POVERTY AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION IS ONE OF
THE BEST PASS OUT OF POVERTY --
BUT THE SIZE ALSO SHOWS.
THAT MAKING FAMILIES POOR --
DOESN'T HELP THEIR CHILDREN.
AT THE SCHOOL IT DOESN'T HELP
THEM STAY IN SCHOOL IT DOESN'T
HELP THEM GRADUATE.
US SO WE ARE IMMENSELY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND AND TO SPONSOR
IT.
AND WE URGE ARRIVAL AND IN
SUPPORT OF CHILDREN AND OTHER
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT THEY
RESIDE.
AFTERNOON JANICE CAM WITH
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND I'M HERE
IS A PROUD I'M A CO SPONSOR OF
AB.
TWO EIGHTY THREE CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND A SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT TO REMOVE
THE COW WORKS PENALTY FOR NOT
VACCINATING.
LET'S BE CLEAR CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA AND
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND NATIONAL
HAS A NEARLY FIFTY YEAR RECORD.
OF SUPPORTING REQUIRED
IMMUNIZATION FOR ALL CHILDREN.
OUR ORGANIZATIONS POSITION IS
THAT THE ONLY ACCEPTABLE REASON
FOR NOT VACCINATING.
IS WHEN A CHILD'S MEDICAL
CONDITION CONTRA INDICATES THAT.
HOWEVER WE NEED EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
TO ENCOURAGE IMMUNIZATION.
STRATEGIES THAT WILL SUPPORT AND
EMPOWER FAMILIES TO ACCESS ALL
THE SERVICES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
IN MEDI CAL.
NOT POLICIES THAT ARE
INEFFECTIVE AND DRIVE FAMILIES
FURTHER INTO POVERTY.
WE SUPPORT POLICIES THE BUILD ON
FAMILY STRENGTH AND AVOID
CREATING BARRIERS STIGMA AND
FURTHER HARDSHIPS.
PENALTIES ARE AN ILL CONCEIVED
POLICY ATTEMPT TO FORCE FAMILIES
TO VACCINATE OR RISK THEIR CAO
WORKS BENEFITS.
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO WONDER
ANYMORE IF THESE WILL WORK
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEY DON'T.
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATES THAT
FAMILIES LIVE IN POVERTY
FAMILIES LIVING IN POVERTY ARE
NOT SERVED BY.
BY A PENALTY CUTTING INTO THEIR
LIMITED RESOURCES.
SEVERAL STATES HAVE ATEMPTED
PENALTIES AS A STRATEGY AND A
STUDY REVIEWING A FDC PENALTIES
FOR NON COMPLIANCE.
IN MARYLAND FOUND THAT ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS DON'T AFFECT BANKS
VACCINATION RATES.
A SIMILAR STUDY FOUND ON WHICH
PROGRAMS FOUND THAT SUPPORTING
AND EDUCATING FAMILIES.
DID INCREASE IMMUNIZATION RATES.
PENALTIES BUILD AN ARCHAIC IDEAS
ABOUT RACE AND CLASS.
AN IDEA THAT PEOPLE LIVING IN
POVERTY NEW TWENTY FORCE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
PENALTIES NEGLECT WHAT WE KNOW
WORKS PROVIDING HEALTH EDUCATION.
HELP WITH TRANSPORTATION.
ELECTRONIC IMMUNIZATION RECORD
KEEPING.
EXPANDING CLINIC HOURS AND OTHER
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE
BARRIERS AND BURDENS ON FAMILIES.
FOR THESE REASONS CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIA IS CO
SPONSORING AB.
TWO TWO EIGHTY THREE BECAUSE
REMOVING THE PENALTIES NOT
DRIVING FAMILIES INTO FURTHER
HARDSHIP.
IT'S A MUCH BETTER.
MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACH
IMMUNIZATION THE COW WORKS
PENALTIES HAVE EVER BEEN THANK
YOU.
THANK.
YOU FOR BEFORE THAT --
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND I'D LIKE
TO TAKE ROLE PLEASE.
RAZ I HEAR MY OFFICE HERE
ARAMBULA.
CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
THANK YOU WE DO A POOR.
KEVIN AS THE COLUSA CALIFORNIA
ONE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS ONE OF
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL FONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MOVE THE BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ONE HELLO WELL THE PROJECT ON
BEHALF OF EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND
EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT TO
THE MEMBERS QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS STRIPS.
OF JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE
AUTHOR THE BILL'S THINGS A GOOD
BILLS I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
TODAY -- I
THINK WE SHOULD NOT BE
PENALIZING --
PARENTS INCOME FAMILIES SPECIAL
THOSE WERE STRUGGLING THROUGH --
ECONOMICS --
BUT I THINK THIS IN THIS AND SO --
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CHOI.
THANK YOU I ALSO WOULD LIKE --
TO ASK A QUESTION AND THEN I DO.
UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT --
BR AT THE ARE TRYING --
TO MAKE IT UP.
LHASA.
CUMBERSOME.
FOR OTHER FAMILIES SO WILL
RECEIVE A CAD WORK UP AND
BENEFITS --
BUT IT IS --
NOT DEBATE NOT TO DEBATE THE THE
FOXY NATION.
IN A REQUIREMENTS WHETHER THE
GOOD OR BAD.
MAY UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT THE
WIDE THIS WAS MAY. TO REQUIRE.
OXIDATION PROOFS OF BEFORE THE
BENEFIT CAN BE RECEIVED THAT
BECAUSE MAYBE BECAUSE SAID NOT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
PROBABLY MANY --
PEOPLE WERE AMONG THE CAL WORKS
TO RECIPIENTS SO --
CHILDREN DID NOT THE VACCINATION
SO USUALLY UP.
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND IS --
THE SCHOOL IS STILL REQUIRE
VACCINATION PROOF SO.
AT THE HEALTH AND ROMAN.
SO THIS IS SO YOUR UNNECESSARY
WORK WHEN THEY APPLY.
FOR FOOD STAMPS NO THE BENEFITS.
SO IT IS --
ELIMINATING ONE MORE GOVERNMENT
RATS IN A WET PAPER SO I'M OR
FOR THAT THE US.
BUT THE HOW IF AND WHEN.
IF THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN.
ARE AMONG.
OUR LOW INCOME FAMILY TEND TO BE --
HIGHER THAN.
MAYBE AT THE GROUP WAS CHILDREN
SO -- ARE
THERE ANY.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING FREE
VACCINATION.
CENTERS SO WHAT.
THEY ARE GIVEN --
FREE VACCINATIONS. FOR OUR
CHILDREN FROM THE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
WE NEED TO FOCUS UPON AND HELP
THEM.
AND NOT TO AFFECT THAT THERE.
ARE A MONTHLY WHATEVER'S
HAPPENED THEY RECEIVED.
A RATHER THAN PENALIZE THING.
SO WHAT IS A NOTHING YOU KNOW TO
A MAN YOUR BILL AT THIS MOMENT
BUT THE SINCE YOU SEEM TO BE
INTERESTED IN THIS AREA.
MY YOU KNOW INTEREST WOULD BE.
FOR YOU TO FOR THE LOOK INTO.
AND THE PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES.
UP FOR CHILDREN TO GET THE FREE
VACCINATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A YOU KNOW
FREE BUT THE NATION --
ALSO SOME OF THE FAMILIES HAVE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUE.
SO WHAT WOULD DEFINITELY BE THE
CONTINUE WORKING WITH FROM AND
PROVIDE THEM THE TRANSIT --
TRANSPORTATION AND ALSO
RECEIVING THE BUT THE NATION GO
GO A 100% CORRECT IS ALREADY IN
OUR THE EDUCATIONAL COLD TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
ALL CHILDREN IN A ROLE IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL OF HAVE TO SHOW SO
ON THIS IS JUST REMOVED TO YOU A
DUPLICATE REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE
CAL WORK OF A RECEIVING.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU CHOI
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
THIS IS A REAL QUICK GUIDE.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND ENDS CUTTING SOME OF
THE RED TAPE THAT'S IT AND THE
WAY TO MAKE SURE FAMILIES GET
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
ESPECIALLY FOR THE KIDS SO --
YOU'LL HAVE MY SUPPORT ON THIS
TODAY THANK YOU VERY SHARE.
I I ALSO WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TAT WE WE ALL UNDERSTAND
ATTENDANCE IS IMPORTANT WILL
UNDERSTAND IMMUNIZATIONS ARE
IMPORTANT.
BUT THERE'S NO NEED TO OVER
BURDENED FAMILIES THAT ARE
ALREADY --
AT THE POVERTY LEVEL THAT ARE
REQUESTING BENEFITS AND TO PUT
SOMETHING ELSE ON ANOTHER
REQUIREMENT. FOR THEM I THINK
THAT THAT IMPOSING FINANCIAL
PENALTIES IS JUST NOT THE WAY TO
GO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
THE WITNESSES THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ALL RIGHT --
MR TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MATHIS SECOND BY MISTER
GIBSON TO PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAMOS HI YES I AM
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE ARAMBULA.
CHOI HI CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE [inaudible]
STONE AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE VOTE IS CURRENTLY.
FIVE WE'RE GOING TO FIVE TO ZERO
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
MR FRAZIER TO LIKE TO PRESENT ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B.
[inaudible]
THREE ONE ONE THE BILL
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF EIGHTY
THREE ONE ONE WHICH WOULD REPEAL
WELFARE AN INSTITUTION CODE.
FOUR SIX NINE OH POINT.
SIX CURRENT CODE THAT SAYS
DEFINITIONS OF FULL AND HALF A
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SERVICES
CONTRACTED BY THE REGIONAL
CENTERS.
ALMOST A DECADE AGO DEFINITIONS
FOR BILLING WERE MAY MANDATED.
AS A COST SAVINGS MEASURE
FOLLOWING THE RECESSION WHEN
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTERS WERE
DRASTICALLY CUT. FOR YEARS THE
CODE SECTION HAS BEEN CHALLENGED
IN COURT WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE HALF THE BILLING
REQUIREMENTS OCCURRING IN JUST.
THE LAST YEAR.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DECEPTIVE
ABILITIES.
I HAVE HEARD FROM PROVIDERS THAT
HAVE.
THAT HAVING TO MANAGE THE HALF
AND FULL THE BILLING RECORDS
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT BURDEN.
AND AS NICK NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
MULTIPLE SERVICES SERVICES
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE REPORTED
LOSSES AS RESULT OF IMPLEMENTING
THE HALF DAY BILLING.
RULE.
WITH ME TODAY ARE TWO EXPERTS
BERRY GIORGINI.
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES.
ASSOCIATION AND WILL SANFORD
FROM FUTURES EXPLORED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS VERY JOURNEY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER FOR
CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
AS HE MENTIONED IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS THERE THIS HAVE TO
BILLING PROGRAM AND THE RULES
AROUND HALF A BILLING ARE A
RELIC OF THE RECESSION ERA.
CUTS THAT WERE FACING THE STATE
DISABILITY SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW DID ARE WE CONTRIBUTED
MORE THAN OUR SHARE DURING THAT
DEBT DURING THAT TIME AND WE'RE
WE'RE NOW DECADE BEYOND THE
GREAT RECESSION AND YET WE'RE
STILL LIVING WITH SOME OF THESE
RECESSION ERA CUTS.
THE HAVE THE BILLING --
RULES IN PARTICULAR ARE
PROBLEMATIC FOR FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS FOR ONE SET A
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO
ATTEND PROGRAM FOR MORE THAN 65%
OF THE DAY.
IN ORDER TO BILL FOR FULL DAY --
WAS 65% I MEAN EVEN IF IT WAS A
HALF DAY BILLING YOU KNOW 50%
WOULD BE MORE REASONABLE BUT
MORE BROADLY IT CREATES A LOT OF
CHALLENGES BOTH FOR PROVIDERS OF
SERVICES AND CONSUMERS
THEMSELVES. FOR PROVIDERS WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE REGULATIONS WHICH REQUIRE US
TO TRACK --
FOR TIME FOR THE DAY SO
TYPICALLY WHAT'S IN STORE COULD
IN THE CASES OF SOMEONE'S IN
PROGRAM FOR THE DAY IT'S A ONE
AND IF THEY'RE NOT THERE.
TO ZERO SO BY IT RE IMPLEMENTING
THIS PROGRAM YOU KNOW JUST FOUR
DAYS BEFORE THE START OF THE
FISCAL YEAR --
LAST ARE FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR
YOU KNOW PROVIDERS HAD TO
SCRAMBLE TO PUT TOGETHER SOME
SORT OF ADMINISTRATIVE TRACKING
SYSTEM TO TRACK THESE THESE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE HAVE TO
BILLING --
AS FAR AS CONSUMERS GO IT ALSO
MEANS YOU KNOW THIS IS A
FINANCIAL HIT TO PROVIDERS I
KNOW THAT THE STATE HAS YOU KNOW
PUT A PRICE TAG ON IT BUT I I
DON'T THINK ANYONE'S REALLY
CAPTURED THE THE TRUE REFLECTION
I THINK. ONE OF OUR PER AND
REVENUE I THINK MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SYSTEM IS ALREADY
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED SO ANY
OF THESE CUTS BEING BROUGHT BACK
IS USUALLY PROBLEMATIC --
AND FROM A CONSUMER PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S A PROBLEM WE HAVE WE HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CLOSING WE
HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE HURTING --
AND WEIGHTLIFTING PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T HIRE STAFF EVERY
DOLLAR THEY'RE NOT PULLING IN
AND REVENUE IS ANOTHER DOLLAR
THEY'RE NOT PUTTING INTO
SERVICES.
FURTHERMORE SOME OF THOSE
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE COMPLICATED
ATTENDANCE RATES MAY END UP
FINDING THEMSELVES NOT BEING
SERVED BY A PROVIDER GOING
FORWARD BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE
IT WORK I MEAN PROVIDER STILL
HAVE TO STAFF FOR THE FULL DAY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
SOMEBODY'S THERE FOR THREE HOURS
AND FIFTY SIX MINUTES.
OR THREE HOURS AND FIFTY EIGHT
MINUTES SO YOU KNOW FOR THESE
REASONS WILL --
ADMINISTRATIVELY AND FINANCIALLY
AND AND ON THE IMPACT CONSUMERS
MOST PRINCIPALLY --
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE HOPE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WELL SEVERAL FEATURES EXPORTER
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER FOR RAISING THIS ISSUE
WHEN WE BROUGHT TO HIM WHEN IT
CAME OUT JUNE TWENTY SEVENTH
THAT WE HAD EMPLOYMENT ON JULY
FIRST.
THE IMPACT TO CONSUMERS REALLY
IS WE ARE IN AN AGE OF HIGH
EXPECTATIONS AND HIGH BELIEVES
THAT OUR FOLKS TO BE VALUABLE
AND CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY. TO DO THAT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO BE TREATED IN THE
THIS BILL OR THIS THE WAY THIS
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED.
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO COULD GO AND
MEET OUR FOLKS AT BART RIDE WITH
BART COME BACK THEN GO HOME FROM
THAT VERSES COMING TO A LOCATION
A CENTER.
WHICH WOULD GIVE THEM A FULL
PROGRAM DAY.
THEY MADE US APART INDEPENDENTLY
THEY GO THEY DO THEIR ACTIVITIES
THEY DO WHAT THEY WANNA DO THEY
GO HOME.
THEY'RE ONLY THERE FOR HALF A
DAY.
SO OUR STAFF PURSUE SUPPORTING
TO OTHER PEOPLE THAT ENTIRE TIME.
WE'VE LOST THAT REVENUE FOR THAT
THAT THING IN OUR CASE IT'S
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH WHICH IS ABOUT THE
EQUIVALENT THREE DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONALS.
I CAN'T ELIMINATE.
A STAFF PERSON TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THE OTHER TWO FOLKS
STILL NEED SUPPORT.
SO THERE'S NO WAY THIS IS YOU
KNOW BASICALLY WAY FOR THE STATE
TO SAVE MONEY I WAS THERE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND TEN I WAS A
PART OF THE GROUP THAT WAS
TASKED WITH TRYING TO SAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF MONEY.
AND WAS ALWAYS SO WE CAN DO THIS
IN THAT SHORT TERM TEN YEARS
LATER.
HE GOT REIMPLEMENTED AND REALLY
DOES HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
HOW FOLKS CAN REALLY BE AND
COMMUNITY AS WE GO FORWARD AND
MOVE FORWARD --
WE HAVE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER SYSTEM THAT'S DEPENDENT ON
US.
ENCOURAGE OUR FOLKS TO BE
INTEGRATED IN INDEPENDENT THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS WORKS IN THE EXACT OPPOSITE
WAY BECAUSE IT IS IN IN FROM
REINFORCES PEOPLE TO GO TO A
LOCATION TO BE THERE ALL DAY.
BECAUSE THEN I GET A FULL DAY
BILLING.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO.
BUT THAT'S WHAT IS GONNA HAPPEN
THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO CHRISTY THOUGHT A BRIDGE
AND ON BEHALF OF EDUCATE
ADVOCATE EMPOWER FAMILY
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS WRECK
ROLLINS REPRESENT HARKIS SO SHE
XIN REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IN.
SUPPORT OF OUR PROVIDER
COMMUNITY AND WE CLEAN THIS UP.
OUTLAW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JORDAN AND SEE WITH THE ARK IN
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
UP MIRANDA POND I'M A PARENT
WITH FAMILY VOICES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE.
HOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS?
AT IT IS TO MATHIS SHREDDERS
REALLY WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FOR NASA LIKE AND
COME ALONG WITH YOU AND WE HONOR
CO AUTHORS ON THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE GET THIS DONE.
THE OWNER TO HAVE YOU
[inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
YES SIR [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
PLACE.
YOU CAME TO THE RIGHT COMMITTEE
THE I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR THOSE WITH DISABILITIES.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT MANY OF US ARE UNAWARE OF
UNTIL IT'S BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THAT PERSON
BRINGS IT FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT.
WE DO HAVE WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST THAT AGAIN YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE.
TO THIS INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
PUMMELED USUALLY IT'S THE IT'S
THE AREA THEY GO CUT FIRST WHEN
THAT WHEN THERE'S A RECESSION
BUT THEY FORGET TO RESTORE.
AFTER AFTER WE'VE BECOME FLUSH.
WEARE IN DIRE NEED OF PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE THIS YOU
KNOW DISABLED POPULATION AS A
WHOLE -- AND
YOU LOOK AT HOW WE TREATED THIS
THIS ENTITY.
WHO'S TAKING CARE OF THE MOST
FRAGILE.
AND TRYING TO CREATE
SUSTAINABILITY.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING
FOR THIS BILL AND AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OFFICE OF CO AUTHOR.
BUT THIS REALLY DOES NEED TO GO
FORWARD AND MAKE THIS RIGHT AS
ONE OF THE STEPS TO SUPPORT AN
INDUSTRY THAT ABSOLUTELY IS
ESSENTIAL IN THE CARE OF THESE
PEOPLE.
THANK YOU.
I RESPECT THIS RED BOOK.
GOOD ENDING HOWEVER WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MATHIS A SECOND
BY MISTER GIBSON.
MOTION IS TO DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE.
RAMOS I YES I AM MATHIS.
MATHIS I ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I IF FIVE ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS PSYCHOMETRIC THANK YOU.
SOME MISTER MISTER BONTA.
ITEM NUMBER SIX ACR
[inaudible]
ONE MR BONTA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
COLLEAGUES IN STAFF THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
A C. R. ONE ACR ONE CONDEMNS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSED
CHANGES.
THAT TARGET ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND CAUSE HARDSHIP
TO UNTOLD.
NUMBERS OF IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO
REALIZE THEIR OWN AMERICAN DREAM.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS RUN
CONTRARY TO CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
AND BIPARTISAN EFFORTS THAT
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
SUPPORTING AND INCLUDING
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS IN OUR
STATE.
UNDER THE IMMIGRATION AND
NATIONALITY ACT AN INDIVIDUAL
SEEKING ADMISSION TO THE US OR
SEEKING TO OBTAIN LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS MAY BE
DEEMED INADMISSIBLE.
OR DENIED PERMANENT RESIDENCE IF
THE INDIVIDUAL IS LIKELY AT ANY
TIME TO BECOME WHAT'S KNOWN AS A
PUBLIC CHARGE.
ON OCTOBER TENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY PROPOSED NEW
REGULATIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
CHARGE DETERMINATIONS THE
REGULATIONS WOULD EXPAND THE
LIST OF BENEFITS CONSIDERED WHEN
MAKING THAT DETERMINATION. TO GO
BEYOND CASH ASSISTANCE WHICH IT
HAD BEEN THINGS LIKE KENNETH AND
CAL WORKS. TO INCLUDE MEDICAID
MEDICARE PART D..
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OR SNAP
SECTION EIGHT HOUSING VOUCHERS
AND OTHER FEDERALLY SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS WOULD
ALSO CONSIDER THE AGE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL.
BEING UNDER EIGHTEEN FOR OVER
SIXTY ONE WOULD BE SEEN AS A
NEGATIVE.
I WOULD ALSO CONSIDER THE
ABSENCE OF CURRENT EMPLOYMENT OR
LACK OF PROSPECT OF EMPLOYMENT
THE USE OF PUBLIC BENEFITS
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY.
MEDICAL CONDITIONS AND INCOME
LEVEL SO LITERALLY IF YOU'RE
YOUNG OR IF YOU'RE OLD IF YOU'RE.
SICK OR IF YOU'RE POOR ALL WOULD
COUNT AGAINST YOU.
THIS LATEST MOVE IS AN ATTACK IN
MY VIEW ON CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
AND WELL BEING THESE PROPOSED
CHANGES TARGET LOW INCOME
WORKING IMMIGRANTS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
AND LOW WAGE LABORERS HEALTH
CARE ACCESS HOUSING AND
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
HELP ALL PEOPLE.
AND THEIR FAMILIES STAY HEALTHY
WORK THRIVE.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY AND
THESE CHANGES HAVE REAL IMPACTS
WE'VE SEEN THEM ALREADY.
THE FEAR OF BEING DEEMED A
PUBLIC CHARGING DENIED LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS OR ENTRY TO
THE US OR POTENTIALLY BEING
SUBJECT TO DEPORTATION. FOR
SEEKING ESSENTIAL BENEFITS
CREATES ADDITIONAL FEAR AMONG
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND IT
ALSO CREATES A CHILLING EFFECT.
THAT WILL UNDERMINE ACCESS TO
THESE CRITICAL THING OF NOTE IS.
OVER 70% OF THE LIVES TOUCHED BY
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS OUR
CHILDREN.
INVESTING IN NUTRITION HEALTH
CARE AND OTHER ESSENTIAL NEEDS.
KEEP CHILDREN LEARNING PARENTS
WORKING AND FAMILY STRONG.
SO YOU SEE ARE ONE CONDEMNS THE
PROPOSED CHANGES AND URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO RECONSIDER.
AND ROLL BACK THESE CHANGES
WHICH WILL LIKELY HARM THE
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC WELL BEING
OF THE STATE AND THE NATION. FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
LARGEST IMMIGRATION POPULATION
AS A STATE IN THE NATION BOTH
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
CALIFORNIA IS STRONGER WHEN
RESIDENTS IN NEED ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT SAFETY NET WITHOUT
FEAR FOR THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILY.
OR THEIR FUTURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON ACR.
ONE AND WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
DEPEND GAG ASIA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER.
A CO SPONSOR OF THIS RESOLUTION
AND JUSTIN RAZA REPRESENTING
ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES ALSO A CO
SPONSOR OF THE RESOLUTION.
GET FIRST WITNESS.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEPHEN BACK
MOESHA I REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR ACR ONE AND
GUIDE CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
AND THE EXPANSION OF THE PUBLIC
CHARGE RULE --
BY LEAVING THE PROTECTING
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES CAMPAIGN FOR
THE STATE.
THE PUBLIC CHARGE RULES ENOUGH
OF A CAN HAS LONG STOCK FEEL
FEAR.
AND AMONG IMMIGRANTS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW A PERSON SEEKING
ADMISSION TO THE UNITED STATES
FOR TRYING TO ADJUSTER STATUS IS
AN ELIGIBLE IF THE INDIVIDUAL IS
DEEMED A PUBLIC CHARGE --
OR PRIMARILY DEPENDENT ON THE
GOVERNMENT FOR SUBSISTENCE.
THE PROPOSED CHANGE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MARKS A
DANGEROUS AND SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION FROM THE CURRENT RULED.
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS MAY BE UNABLE TO
ADJUST THEIR STATUS AND
COUNTLESS NUMBERS OF IMMIGRANTS
WILL DESCEND ROLE FROM SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS THAT KEEP THEIR
FAMILY'S HOUSE FAT AND HEALTHY.
EVEN THOUGH THE RULE CHANGE HAS
YET TO TAKE A FACT I'M AS WAS
MENTIONED FRONTLINE WORKERS ARE
REPORTING MASS DESCEND ROLE MAN
FROM PROGRAMS LIKE SNAP MEDICAID
MEDICARE --
BUT EVEN THOSE THAT ARE AFFECTED
BY THE PROPOSED RULE LIKE WAKE
PHAM WHICH KEEPS PREGNANT WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WATCH --
ENABLES PREGNANT WOMEN CHILDREN
TO GET THE CRITICAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY NEED --
THESE ARE FAMILIES THAT MAKE UP
STRONG MEMBERS OF OUR STATE.
THEY CONTRIBUTE FIFTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO THAT --
FEDERAL ECONOMY WITH THEIR TAXES
AND TWENTY SIX BILLION IN STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES.
HURTING IMMIGRANTS HURTS ALL OF
US.
AS A RESULT OF CA PC ASIAN
HEALTH SERVICES --
AND OTHER ADVOCATES COMMITMENT
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY I'M SUBMITTED
OVER TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND COMMENTS --
IN RESPONSE TO THE POST RULE I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO IT.
CALIFORNIA'S RESIDENTS I'M IN
IMMIGRANTS ARE LOOKING TO THE
STATE'S LEADERS FOR PROTECTION
AN ACTION IN THIS CRITICAL
MOMENT AND AS SUCH WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
ACR.
ONE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE IS CO
SPONSOR.
MY NAME'S JUSTIN ROWS --
HERE FOR ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
WERE FORTY SIX YEAR OLD.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
HEADQUARTERED IN OAKLAND AND
PROVIDE INTEGRATED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES --
TO TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PATIENTS IN FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES.
SO PUBLIC CHARGE LAST READ IT'S
UGLY HEAD IN THE NINETIES AND WE
WERE SURPRISE THEN THE API'S
WERE ACTUALLY THE HARDEST TO BE
HIT BY IT.
AT ASIANHEALTH SERVICES WE HAD
A YOUNG MOTHER WHO LIVED IN
OAKLAND.
AFTER WELFARE REFORM SHE WAS
STOPPED AT THE SAN FRANCISCO
AIRPORT ON HER WAY TO CHINA
WHERE I AN S. HAD DISCOVERED
THAT SHE DELIVERED HER TWINS
WHILE ON MEDI CAL.
AND DEMANDED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN REPAYMENT ON THE SPOT.
THAT'S MONEY THAT OBVIOUSLY SHE
DIDN'T HAVE AND THEY IMMEDIATELY
DEPORTED HER ON A PLANE TO CHINA
WITHOUT HER BABIES --
MY COLLEAGUES TRIED AND TRIED IN
VAIN TO FIGHT THE CASE
INDIVIDUALLY IN COURT BUT WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL.
THE TWINS WERE RAISED IN OAKLAND
BY THEIR GRANDMOTHER FOR TWENTY
YEARS. TO US THIS IS PERSONAL
THIS MOTHER WAS OUR PATIENT.
WE PROMISE OUR PATIENTS SIGN UP
FOR MEDI CAL YOU'LL BE SAFE.
AND NOW AGAIN WE FIGHT YET
ANOTHER ANTI IMMIGRANT RULE FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
PUBLIC CHARGES IN COHERENT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY STATED GOAL.
AND IT THREATENS HEALTH GAINS
WE'VE MADE AT MULTIPLE LEVELS
THE INDIVIDUAL THE FAMILY THE
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE AT ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE --
ON THE C. R. ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA REALLY QUICKLY PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE GOING TO
BE TARGETED DISPROPORTIONATELY
BASED ON ASSUMPTIONS AND
PERCEPTIONS.
OF WHETHER THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO SOCIETY OR WILL BE A PUBLIC
CHARGE THANK YOU.
JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
JANICE CAN ALLEN CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
LINDA TENER WHAT'S ON THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OLGA SHILOH WITH LAW
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
RICK ROLLINS REPRESENT ARCA SO
SHE XIN REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHO WAS LIKE A FATHER WITH THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE EICHER GONNA ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE BILLION FIRST HAVE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GEORGE LINDSEY WITH THE RK
CALIFORNIA UNITED WILL POSE A
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES ALSO SYMPATHETIC
WITH THOSE FROM AROUND THE WORLD
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPED A
DISABILITIES WHO WILL WILL BE
CONSIDERED A PUBLIC CHARGE.
THANK YOU.
KATHY SAID KNOWING THAT THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LA HANDLED ON HERE ON BEHALF OF
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ZACHARY QUARREL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
NOT YET.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
[inaudible]
NUMBER BONTA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A COUPLE OTHER COMMENTS OR
SECOND AT LEAST.
THANK YOU STONE.
BACK TO CHOI THANK YOU CHAIR I
HAVE A QUESTION --
MINOR AND AND OF THE QUESTION
NOT QUITE.
RELATED TO THE CONTENT TO MORE
FORMALITY HERE --
I SEE NEW REGULATIONS.
A PREVIOUS EXISTING REGULATIONS
DO WE HAVE THAT THE STATEMENT.
NEW IMMIGRANTS SO WOULD NOT
BECOME THE PUBLIC CHARGE.
OKAY SO NEW REGULATIONS SO HOW
IS IT DIFFERENT IF CAN RESTATED
I COULDN'T.
REALLY MAKE THAT THAT THE FIRST.
WITH A TARGETING ON THE CHILDREN
WHILE ANYTHING ELSE.
GET THE NUMBER ONE QUESTION.
NUMBER TWO IS NOT RELATED TO THE
CONTENT.
BUT THE I HAD THAT EXPERIENCE TO
WITH MY B. L. ON NOT.
YOUR CONCERN DAY [inaudible]
I WAS SUPPOSED TO PRESENT THAT --
AJ ARE AS I REMEMBER WAS A FIVE
Y..
SIX BUT THEY LATER --
MY RESOLUTION HAD TO BE
POSTPONED TO NEXT THURSDAY.
EVEN THROW UP ON MY GUESTS OF
FROM LONG DISTANCE SELECT A LATE
AT TO COME UP HERE BECAUSE TO
HELP OF ONE LANGUAGE.
WHEN THE LETTER --
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
A YOU SEE OUR INSTEAD WHAT AG R..
AJ ARE IS A RELATED.
TO MY ISSUE WAS NOT FEDERAL
MATTER.
US IS THE OPPOSITE US IS AS A
ACR ONE IS THE RIGHT AGENCY I
WANT THIS IS RELATED TO THE
FEDERAL MATTER.
SO BEFORE YOU RUN INTO ANY
TECHNICAL.
ISSUES I DON'T KNOW WHAT THOUGH
THIS BODY HAS THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE THAT CHARACTER WELL YOU
HAVE TO GO BACK --
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE BECAUSE
IT WAS ON NAM MY A PROBLEM AT
THAT TIME.
THE ALLEGED COUNCIL ISSUED THE
OF BUT IN THE BEGINNING AS A AJ
ARE LATER IT WAS CAUGHT AND THEN
I GOT PENALIZED --
INFORMED NO REGIONAL IN ON ME OR
MY STAFF.
FOR SO I'M GIVING YOU PRE
WARNING ON THIS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
I'LL TAKE A SECOND ITEM FIRST
THANK YOU FOR THE HEADS UP I'LL
KEEP AN EYE ON THAT --
TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION HOW IS
THIS DIFFERENT YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE THERE IS THE CONCEPT OF
PUBLIC CHARGE --
CURRENTLY IN OUR IN OUR FEDERAL
LAW IT'S IT'S NARROW IN ITS
DEFINITION AND AND THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED UNNECESSARY IN A
REASONABLE PROPOSED EXPANSION.
TO INCLUDE THINGS LIKE AB THAT
SUPPORT.
WORKING IMMIGRANT FAMILIES LIKE
HEALTH PROGRAMS LIKE HOUSING
PROGRAMS.
LIKE NUTRITION PROGRAMS THAT
ALSO TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION
THINGS LIKE YOUR AGE AS I
MENTIONED --
THAT IT WOULD IT'S LITERALLY A
AB OVER SIXTY ONE IT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT ENGLISH PROFICIENCY YOUR
MEDICAL CONDITION YOUR INCOME
LEVEL SO --
IT'S AN EXPANSION THAT TAKES
INTO CONSIDERATION CRITERION
THAT HAVE NEVER BEFORE BEEN USED
AND NEED NOT BE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SAYING NONE WE DO HAVE.
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A FIRST FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
DOCTOR STONE SECOND.
PLEASE TAKE LONG.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED RAMOS.
HI RES I AM MATHIS ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE.
STONE AYE. FOUR ZERO WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
ALL RIGHT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE AB THREE FORTY
ONE MAIENSCHEIN DO I HAVE A
MOTION.
EMOTIONS SECOND PLEASE TAKE LONG.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR RAMOS HI
RES ONLINE MATHIS.
ARAMBULA.
CHOI CHOI I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE AYE GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I CONSENT COUNTERS.
FIVE ZERO WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS --
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE --
TAKE US THROUGH EACH OF THESE
AND LET US KNOW WHICH ONE STILL
IN MOTION.
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT LOTUS.
FIVE TO ZERO ARAMBULA.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TO AB
THREE ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTERS [inaudible]
FIVE TO ZERO ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM THREE WE
NEED A MOTION [inaudible]
MOTION.
MOTION FOR MR MAIENSCHEIN SECOND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RAMOS.
HI RES I AM MATHIS [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOI I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I A
STONE [inaudible]
STONE AWAY.
VOTERS FIVE ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX WE NEED A MOTION.
WHAT WAS THAT YEAH?
THE MOTION IS THE PASS AS
AMENDED IT TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RANTS.
RAMOS I AM MATHIS.
ARAMBULA.
CHOI.
CHOICE I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I A
GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
STONE [inaudible]
STONE HI.
CURRENT VOTERS.
FIVE TWO ZERO LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
WE'RE NOT
STAND.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE AS FIVE TO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I ARAMBULA GIPSON CURRENT
VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY THREE CURRENT VOTE
[inaudible]
SEVEN TO ZERO AT ARAMBULA.
FILE ITEM TO AB THREE ELEVEN
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA.
GIPSON.
FILE ITEM THREE AB THREE THREE
SEVEN CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS I ARAMBULA GIPSON CURRENT
VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE A. B.
FOR TWENTY SIX CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
GIPSON.
KERN VOTE.
FIVE TWO ZERO FILE ITEM SIX ACR
ONE CURRENT VOTE. FORTY ZERO
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
GIPSON.
CURRENT VOTE FOR DESSERT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
NUMBER --
ONE WITH --
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW --
COLOR CODED.
PART OF THE COURT.
WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THINKING.
OF THE EARLY ON RIGHT
[inaudible]
THE BILL
YEAH
.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FROM FOR ON
OUR BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CURRENT CREDIT SIX TO
ZERO GIPSON.
AYE GIPSON AYE FINAL VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM ONE AB
TWO EIGHTY THREE CURRENT VOTE --
SEVEN TO ZERO FINAL VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM TO AB
THREE ELEVEN CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO GIPSON AYE GIPSON
AYE FINAL VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM THREE AB
THREE THREE SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
SIX TO ZERO GIPSON AYE GIPSON
AYE FINAL VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO GIPSON HI
GIPSON I FINAL VOTE.
SIX TWO ZERO FILE ITEM SIX ACR
ONE CURRENT VOTE FOR TWO ZERO
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE FINAL VOTE.
FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
MEETING